hi there steve kaufman and today i'm
going to talk to you about how i learn
russian
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe click on the bell to
get notifications so
i was about 60
and my approach to language learning had
always been that you shouldn't focus on
grammar
uh you need to get used to the language
through lots of listening and reading i
had done that with chinese with japanese
you need to get used to the patterns of
the language and not focus on the
itsy-bitsy details of the language
and people said to me that will not work
with russian because russian has very
complex grammar
so that became a bit of a challenge
and also i had always enjoyed you know
reading novels of russian literature in
english when i was young so i thought it
would be cool to be able to read
tolstoy or dostoyevsky in russian so
with that i started learning russian i
began
at that time
link was very much in a sort of
rudimentary stage it would take us three
four five seconds to save an individual
link
but i started obviously you know not
having a full-fledged program at link i
bought books
colloquial
teach yourself living language listened
to those read them as soon as we had
certain things that i could do on link i
started doing them evgeny who is a great
supporter of link in st petersburg
created a lot of great content
as soon as i could
i started into you know audiobooks and
i'm going to give you a brief
view in fact if you look behind me
you'll see
i stacked them up to have a look here
you'll see some of the
dvds some of the videos that i watched
some of the cds that i listened to
the dvds initially was more to to
stimulate me and encourage me
the cds was more for listening i did a
lot of listening
in those days
we weren't yet able to import you know
from youtube and
so forth but we were able to import
some of the classics just the text into
link and then i would listen to
the audio and in fact i'll give you a
brief sort of view of my profile with
russian and you'll see that i began in
2007 more or less and that i had a
period of significant activity which
then
tapered off so first have a look at that
i'm looking at my profile and i get to
my profile by the way by clicking on my
uh image here and then going to profile
and you'll see that i started learning
russian in 2007.
that's a long time ago this is my hours
of listening not accurate because most
of my listening through through this
period has been to
cds watching movies listening to echo
musk v and i'll get into more detail on
what i did if i just look at my
activities on link if i look at my links
created
you'll see that i've been active over a
long period of time even recently i go
in occasionally and read an article
on link and create some links so my
known words total has
grown in this fashion i don't know when
we were starting with link there were
some issues and i ended up with some
negative numbers but that gives you a
brief
sense of how long i've been at russian
it has been a major
love of mine and so i want to get into
some detail about that
all right
now
the first
um
audiobook that i listened to was
kreutzer croissant
by tolstoy because it's short and in
fact
i have it here
okay
and
i listened to it i didn't really
understand it but i was able to import
the uh
text because it's all you know free of
copyright i worked on it
at link i did check off i did a lot of
the classics of russian i can remember
being in a place called silver star
where in fact i was training to ski in
the vasa lopez in sweden and i was you
know out there cross-country skiing
three four five hours a day
while listening to chekhov listening to
tolstoy listening to
um
other
classics of of russian literature go
back to my room look up words
link was very slow three four five
seconds to save each word but i was
determined okay so that's kind of where
it began
uh some of my favorite um
you know
dvds
for example
although my all-time favorite was just
toki romance which to me was the
ultimate exotic russian experience on
the volga 19th century uh some guy from
georgia and so forth but there's a whole
bunch of them this is another great one
you know this was
irony
which is a classic in russian in russia
they watch it apparently every new
year's
uh
i got into some of the uh
some of the more modern ones but i find
that the modern russian there's also
brag somewhere
uh
here we have
but the modern russian movies are a
little more violent the old russian
soviet movies you know
uh
here we have another one
these were great they had a got to get
my glasses on my skull
whatever
and
so that was that however another major
and and i'll give you a bit of a tour
now then maybe of my library
i did want to give you a little bit of
an overview of some of the material that
i have used
for my russian
here for example atseiji
was one of my favorites i listened to it
over and over again the same is true of
yama by cuprin
but these of course were later on
the very first let me see the very first
audiobook that i did was
um the kreutzer sonata croissant sonata
by tolstoy
i did the whole assimil series but of
course as i'll show you when i get to
the books that was only one of the
um ser you know learning materials that
i used
uh of course i watched a lot of russian
videos i went and got some of these dvds
just to display them here for you
uh one of my favorites was sabachi
cersei
you know vinaimir
uh
i mean i could go on and on my favorite
was just okie romance which i wasn't
able to find in a hurry here these are
some of the cds that i listened to
um you know and i have only displaced
some of them because i've got a whole
bookshelf
full of these cds so that's just the
sort of dvd
cd uh section when i say listening and
reading i include reading so i have a
lot of books here
in russian including
books for learning russian and books for
me to read in russian
and i'm sure i have others elsewhere in
my library
of course that's a bit messy here we're
doing work in the house this is my
korean section my german section
and so forth at least of my uh
cds because
the dvds the movies were more to to
encourage and stimulate and motivate me
and it was fun but the learning was from
listening to
the audiobooks and then reading them on
link and saving words and phrases and
accumulating this total of 90 000 some
odd
known words
granted in you know the way there are so
many different forms of the same word
you can't just
start beating your chest and saying i
know 90 000 words but it indicates that
i've done a lot of of reading and where
i've read i've largely
listened
but a major impact on my russian
learning
aside from the tremendous help i got
from evgeny and other tutors there was a
while i should have shown that in my
statistic
there was a while where i was doing a
lot of talking as well because i mean
we're talking about a long period of
engagement with russian so perhaps two
years i didn't speak but then for
another couple of years i'd be on
talking to
elena to
jenny to other tutors number of tutors
that i had linked tutors
and and speaking and learning about
russia and learning russian and it was
just a wonderful wonderful experience
and
but a major influence was eccomas creek
now echomaski is a radio station in
moscow
not very popular in russia
because it's somewhat anti-regime
although in fact there's quite a wide
range of opinion there they have like
you know zuganov the communist is there
you've got uh
uh prokhorov i can't remember it's been
a while now i haven't been listening to
it for a while but you had there's this
imperialist guy
and they have a sort of a
wide range of opinion
i wouldn't call them moderate in any way
they're all very you know emphatic in
what they have to say but if you listen
to a a group of these people you get a
sense of what people are talking about
in russia the big advantage of echo must
be is that every day there are
i don't know a dozen interviews
audio with text so every day
i would import
the text into link i wouldn't bother
importing the audio because i would have
that on my
you know iphone or whatever but i go
through and mine it for words and
phrases i mean i did that for years
every day i would load up with five
interviews i'd be listening in the car
listening everywhere reading
echo was a major
uh influence on
me developing my russian
now russians get on say ah that's uh you
know they're all
american stooges and blah blah blah and
whatever but in fact it's that's not
quite fair there is a variety but as
with any
uh information source you have to pick
and choose and you can't just accept
things at face value and
i don't accept everything at face value
that i hear on that chemistry
however it helped me a great deal
so so basically my experience with
russian was one of discovering first of
all the classics
because there i was able to buy went to
riga latvia to buy
all of these all of these uh
cds i got lots of them which you don't
need to do now because you can find them
online
uh
and i bought all these dvds movies which
you don't need to do now because you can
find them in netflix you can find them
in youtube
um
and and so i was exploring that aspect
of russia but at the same time through
ecommerce i was exploring
daily events russian perspectives on
things happening around the world
russia-us relations russia ukraine
relations russia china relations and so
i was getting a a rather broad base the
other thing that russia did for me is it
got me into the slavic languages it was
my first slavic language
and of course
yeah it is difficult
it is difficult because there are many
things in russian that we don't have in
english we don't have
uh you know we're verbs of motion we
don't have cases we don't have uh
uh you know aspects of verbs
uh a lot of these things and and you can
read the explanations over and over
again but
and they're kind of helpful but the
explanations are not that difficult to
understand except that there's so many
exceptions that you can get confused but
it's getting
developing these habits these patterns
of speech that they have in russian
which are different from english and
that just takes a lot of exposure and
even at that well as i've been away from
russian of course my russian
deteriorates i make more grammatical
mistakes i search for words but again if
i get back into it
if i'm with russian people i hear how
they speak i pick up on how they speak
i start to refresh
you know the habits that i have
you know
lost and acquire new and better habits
so i'm comfortable with where i am in
russian but russian is
uh
because i don't have to write exams in
russian i just have to enjoy the
language but it was also the door into
other slavic languages so
uh after russian i learned czech because
my father my parents were born
in
actually the austro-hungarian empire but
what became czechoslovakia
and uh my father has you know scrapbooks
at home of where he climbed mountains
and did a whole bunch of stuff that was
in the newspapers and now i'm able to
read it so i learned czech czech was a
long road by the way
and then from czech i did polish and
then i did ukrainian and uh a little bit
of uh slovak which is very similar to
czech so it opened up the whole slavic
world
uh so it's been to me it's been a love
affair with russian uh a voyage of
discovery of russian of of the ruskim
the russian world but also the slavic
world
so uh just a quick uh summary i hope
that's helpful to you of how i learned
russian bye for now